Salut ! à la base je voulais sortir
cette vidéo le dernier jour du mois.
Et puis j'ai pris un petit peu de retard au montage
donc ça sort le 1er jour du mois.
C'est pas tellement gênant,
vous allez vite comprendre de quoi il s'agit.
Mais juste avant j'ai des petites précisions à faire
par rapport à la vidéo d'hier.
Le 2nd degré est mort avec internet les gars.
Donc si jamais il est besoin de le préciser,
Quand je dis "je suis un mytho"
C'est du 2nd degré. Il n'y a jamais eu de complice dans la vidéo, vous en avez conscience de ça ou pas ?
Car non ma sœur ne sait pas
se déguiser en Amixem et en Pierre Croce
Désolé...
Une légende était née...
et une légende vient de mourir.
Et truc rigolo, j'ai eu plein de messages de :
"Mais alors si tu avais pas de lunettes tu faisais comment pour voir les micro-expressions ?"
C'est parce que, en fait, avant
je n'étais pas aveugle...
Tu vois ? Je voyais depuis 35ans...
Même je conduis des voitures...
Donc j'arrivais à voir.
Mais c'est vrai que là, maintenant,
je vois beaucoup plus nettement !
Donc c'est pas ça qu'il faut se dire.
C'est pas comment je faisais avant ?
C'est que maintenant :
Je suis une machine de guerre.
[Musique Générique]
Le concept ce mois-ci c'est de faire
un Vlog durant un mois.
Un Vlog par mois.
Il y aura 12 Vlogs dans l'année.
On est le 6 janvier, c'est le premier jour de la tournée, mais ce n'est pas de ça que je vais vous parler.
Je vais vous faire une annonce...
Au mois de novembre
j'ai été contacté pour écrire un livre.
[Voix de Gary en arrière plan]
Il est derrière le paper-board, avec les feuilles
que tu as posées, ça n'a rien a voir ?
[Fabien] : Non, ça c'étaient les feuilles qu'il y
avait dessus... en... ouais, tout à fait.
Donc j'allais vous dire,
avant que Gary me coupe,
Au mois de novembre dernier
j'ai été contacté pour écrire un livre.
Et j'ai dit ok.
Et on m'a dit  : "Ouais, mais il faudra
que ce soit prêt pour fin janvier."
Le manuscrit.
Ce qu'on appelle le manuscrit.
Ce que je vais rendre à l'éditeur.
Et là où il va dire : "Aaah oui, c'est bien,
mais c'est bourré de fautes."
C'est possible qu'il y ait beaucoup de fautes.
Il me reste donc exactement 25 jours
pour écrire les 50 chapitres...
Ce qui ne veut pas dire que je vais
les bâcler.
C'est un petit peu comme
l'année dernière
avec le défi de faire une vidéo
par jour pendant 1 an...
Je vais là me donner le défi d'écrire
2 chapitres par jour pendant 25 jours.
Donc 1 la journée et 1 la nuit, sûrement.
Et je vais faire ça durant
cette tournée intensive de janvier,
en vlogant avec vous,
comme ça vous allez participer
à la création du livre, directement.
Et je vais même vous solliciter
sur les réseaux sociaux
mais vous n'allez pas encore savoir
de quoi ça parle,
vous ne saurez qu'à ce moment là,
dans la vidéo.
Pour que vous soyez directement
DANS le livre,
de plein de manières différentes.
En attendant, ça joue ce soir
pour la première date
Donc il serait bien que je m'active
[Musique]
Il est 19h30 et on va manger
avec Gary.
Juste avant de jouer.
On a pris un petit resto au hasard.
[Fabien] : Dis nous où on est,
comment ça s'appelle ?
[Gary] : Le Sherlock !
[Serveuse] : Bienvenue au Sherlock.
[Musique]
La 1ère représentation
s'est terminée,
Ça s'est bien passé.
Il faut quand même que je vous précise
qu'on est le lendemain matin.
Là je suis à la chambre d'hôtel.
Il y a eu un vrai problème.
C'est à dire que le spectacle fait,
à peu près, 1h30
et on a fait 3h de dédicaces
et de rencontres avec vous après.
Donc ça fait un package de 4h30.
Déjà tout le monde a détesté au théâtre.
Parce qu'ils ont fini beaucoup
plus tard que d'habitude.
Et moi j'étais explosé donc
je suis rentré me coucher directement.
C'est un peu trop long.
Il faut que je m'organise différemment.
En fait je suis très bavard,
je suis pipelette,
j'aime beaucoup parler avec vous.
Mais du coup trop ...
Il faut que je trouve une solution
pour ce soir.
Je ne sais pas encore
comment je vais m'organiser.
Si je ne parle que 2 minutes
avec tout le monde ça va...
Mais ouais, mais 2 x 140,
ça fait 280 minutes...
C'est beaucoup !
Donc je ne sais pas.
Si vous avez une idée dans les commentaires
pour qu'on puisse prendre
du temps ensemble
et en même temps sans faire
le double du temps du spectacle
après le spectacle...
Parce que le vrai problème
que ça génère
c'est que, hier soir,
je n'ai pas écrit en rentrant.
Donc ça veut dire que là je vais ranger un peu tout,
tout mon bord**, tout mon merdi**
[Riant]
J'ai tout mis à l'arrache hier soir.
Et, euh...
Et je vais écrire les 1ers chapitres.
On va essayer ça.
[Musique]
Rangement ET café...
s'il vous plaît.
Je viens d'avoir une super
nouvelle par SMS,
j'ai oublié de vous le dire,
ce soir il y a Superkonar
qui vient voir le spectacle.
Et je suis ravi !
Du coup je suis en train
de me demander,
tous les livres que j'ai lu,
où est-ce qu'ils ont été écrits ?
Çà, ce serait vraiment cool
si les auteurs  nous mettaient
les lieux où ils ont écrit.
Les circonstances dans lesquelles
ils les ont écrit.
Une fois je vous ai parlé du Bullet Journal.
Ça c'en est un !
Et là dedans il y a toutes les idées
que j'ai pour les vidéos de cette année.
Et si je vous installais, près de moi ?
C'est pas maaaal !
Alors pour ce premier chapitre,
je ne vais pas commencer par faire
euh...
un peu d'astuce ou de
mentalisme pur,
il y en aura évidemment dans le livre.
Il y a mon éditrice qui m'a appelée hier
pour me poser une question ;
Elle m'a demandé si je voulais
qu'il y ait des rabats dans le livre
Vous savez dans les bouquins,
par exemple, il y a un rabat ici
et un rabat de l'autre côté.
Et donc je lui ai posé une question
tout à fait logique :
Je lui fais : ça sert à quoi les rabats?
[Riant]
Et sa réponse a été drôle,
Bah écoute ça sert à...
ça...euh... ben... fff...
ça sert...
C'est vrai que ça sert plus à rien les rabats.
Enfin ça maintient un peu le livre
mais il n'y a plus trop de sens.
Et donc moi si ça ne sert à rien
s'il n'y a pas de sens et d'utilité
bah je ne veux pas qu'il y en ait, tu vois ?
Mais du coup ça m'a stimulé
et je me suis dit :
"Ou alors on peut les garder mais
il faut qu'ils aient une utilité."
Il faut qu'on retrouve une utilité.
Et j'ai une idée.
Et là d'un coup, les rabats
ils servent à quelque chose...
Oui j'ai regardé les Simpson
avant de me coucher.
Dans la foulée, aujourd'hui, je pense que
je vais écrire un chapitre sur l'auto ancrage en PNL.
Euh.. Un chapitre sur
le calendrier perpétuel,
je sais que j'ai fait une vidéo
dessus il n'y a pas longtemps,
mais j'aimerais bien le
mettre dans le livre.
Ça sera un chapitre très court,
ça va prendre qu'une page.
Et un chapitre sur le non verbal
pour deviner la pensée d'une personne.
4 chapitres : les 2, déjà, de retard
d'hier et les 2 d'aujourd'hui.
J'ai jusqu'à 21h30 pour les écrire.
Après, de toute manière,
c'est des premiers jets,
ça ne m'empêchera pas
de repasser, ensuite, dessus.
Et si j'arrêtais de parler ?
Et si je m'y mettais ?
Au dessus du bar de l'irlandais
à Lille, il y a un petit bar privé.
Le petit bar des familles de Stéphane
Et on boit un coup-là.
Et il y a quelqu'un qui arrive en fait.
Je ne vous dit pas qui c'est.
Il arrive ici.
Derrière le logo de Jack Daniels
C'est...
Oouuuiii,  on ne voit pas qui c'est !!
[Superkonar] : Oh mentalisme !
[Fabien] : mais c'est incroyable !
[Fab] :Le kinder surprise !
T'es en live... sur rien du tout !
[SK] Ouais, c'est ce que j'allais dire, tu vois ?
[Fab] : Incroyable, hein ?
[Fab] : Bonsoir !
[Ami de SK] salut, ça va ?
[Fab] Amixem, t'as pris un peu, hein ?
[Rires]
[Chanson en live]
[Discussion] : Tu dis que Facebook, ça niq..
Youtube en fait ?
[SK] : Noon...
On est rentré avec gary,
enfin... lui, il est rentré chez lui,
moi, je suis rentré chez moi.
J'avais oublié que je travaillais aujourd'hui
Où allons nous Céline Lewinsky ?
[Céline] On va au FUP, c'est ça ?
[Fab] : Au FUP !
[Cél] : Au Fup, et pas aux putes !
[Fab] : Et pas aux putes... nuance !
[Cél] : On ne serait pas content sinon !
[Fab] bah si on pourrait aussi.
[Fab] Mais, du coup, au lieu d'aller
gagner de l'argent, on irait en perdre.
[Cél] : Et ça, on ne serait pas content du coup !
[Fab] Mais on pourrait gagner des MST...
[Cél] :quand je te dis ...
[Rires]
[Cél] : Je ne trouve pas que
ce soit une bonne idée...
[Fab] : En même temps ça me permettrai de faire
un bon titre et une bonne miniature putaclic.
et je serai donc devant le point virgule
avec d'autres artistes pour le lancement...
Autant vous dire que
les deux chapitres à écrire aujourd'hui
ça va être compliqué...
Donc ça veut dire demain :
quatre chapitres mon gars !
Et ouais...
Parce que en fait elle essaye de faire rentrer le chat
ou le chien ou le poney, je ne sais pas
[Fab] Tu cherches quoi ? Une licorne ?
[Cél] : Vanille !?
Elle crie toujours des parfums
de glace comme ça à la fenêtre.
[Rires de Céline]
L'autre jour elle criait
"pistache, pistache fraise, pistache fraise !"
Mais on n'a pas de glacier, c'est un jardin.
[Cél] : Les tutos relooking de Fabien, n'hésitez pas,
restez bien en place ça va être la régalade !
[Fab au loin] : c'est un nouveau pull,
je pense que vous ne l'avez jamais vu!
[Rires de Céline]
[Fab] C'est énorme !
Tu sais que moi je serais capable
de porter ça tous les jours quasiment,
ou tous les deux jours, hein ?
[Cél] : Mais tu sais que tu m'impressionnes ?
[Cél] : Tous les jours tu serais
capable de le mettre ?
[Fab] Ouais, mais je ne ferai jamais ça !
[Cél] : ah ouais petit côté
la reine des glaces, la reine des neiges...
[Fab] Ben, la reine des glaces :
bah va crier vanille
[Rires]
Pour vous situer un peu dans le temps on est le 8.
C'est ça, hein ? On est le 8 ?
70 000 personnes qui viennent de nous
rejoindre sur la chaine depuis
qu'Amixem m'a proposé
de faire une vidéo avec lui.
J'étais comme un ouf hier soir
en sortant de scène.
Tu sais, il a cassé mon
compteur d'abonnés,  je crois.
J'ose même plus...
ça doit fumer quoi... c'est ouf !
Salut les euh...
les gamers de chez Amixem.
Clap !
[Cél] :Un petit coup de shampoing sec ?
[Fab] Oui d'accord
[Fab] Mais après je fais quoi ?
[Cél] Oh bah tu ne touches plus à rien.
[Fab] D'accord.
[Cél] : C'est du shampoing sec,
[Cél] : Ça c'est l'outil indispensable des gens qui  ont des problèmes de cheveux gras.
[Fab] : Ou qui veulent tuer des gens,
pour les asphyxier aussi...
[Cél] : Oh baaah... cheveux gras ou problèmes de bouche : ça marche sur les deux.
Les loges du point virgule mon pote !
Je jouais là il y a deux ans,
il y a encore les feuilles que
j'utilisais durant le spectacle.
Je pense qu'ils sont nostalgiques.
Maniaques, mais nostalgiques.
Ils gardent mes affaires.
[Musique]
[Fab] : C'est une vraie question, est-ce que ça représente quelque chose de physique ?
[Fab] Dans le réel. Un objet, un animal
ce genre de chose ?
[Fab] Non, c'est un concept plus ?
[La Passante] Je répond là ?
[Fab] Ouais.
[L.P.] Euh... non plus.
[Fab] Non. D'accord mais c'est pas physique,
ça n'existe pas dans la réalité ?
[L.P.] euh... non ça n'existe pas.
[Fab] Ok. Je pense avoir une idée.
[Fab] : Je pense que vous êtes sur le mot "bien"
[Fab] : C'est ça !? oui merci beaucoup
[Les gens autour] : Bravo ! Bravo !
[Une petite fille] : Il a dit quoi comme mot ?
[Fab] : Vous étiez un challenge pour moi !
Attention...
[L.P.] Ah bon ?
[Fab] : Ah ouais, ouais !
[Musique]
[Céline] Qui c'est ?
[Marine] Ben c'est Marine Baousson
qui a une sale gueule...
[Cél] Mais... Mais enfin, bien sûr
que c'est Marine Baousson !
[Marine] Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Tu fais des vlogs toi ?
[Cél] Ben écoute, pour euh...
pour l'autre connard  [Rires]
[Mar.] Il est où l'autre connard ?
[Cél] : Regarde le !
Hop là !
[Mar.] Oh la la...
[Fab] Je vais faire une petite
prédiction à l'avance...
[Cél] Et voilà...
[Mar] Je vais lui demander de faire un truc
pour mon papa, s'il veut bien.
[Cél] Bien sûr.            Prédiction à l'avance...
[Mar.] Bonsoir.
[Cél] Fabien Olicard...
[Mar] Tu vas bien ?  Bonne année.
[Cél] Ben oui et toi ? Bonne année !
[Musique]
[Cél] Monsieur Patrick Chanfray...
[Patrick] Effectivement je dois pouvoir...
[Céline Lewinsky] Là c'est Céline Groussard
[Céline Groussard] Oui, bonsoir.
[Patrick] Pourquoi il n'y a pas de règle ?
[Cél. L] Et Patrick Chanfray. Comment ça va ?
[Pat] : Excessivement bien.
[Cél. L] Et bien comme d'habitude ?
[Pat] : Et voilà.
[Cél. L] Parce que c'est Patrick Chanfray...
[Pat] C'est marrant...
[Pat] Tu filmes vraiment avec de petites choses...
[Pat] On dirait de... de... de l'espo...
de " l'espogniage " !
[Cél L] De l'esponiage ?
[Pat] : Comme de l'espionnage,
mais avec des lettres différentes [Rires]
De retour au bureau avec Mélanie !
Tu sais que dans les commentaires,
il y en a qui demande si tu es ma meuf ?
[Rires]
Et ouais, est-ce que Mélanie
c'est ma meuf ou pas ?
Non, Mélanie on TRAVAILLE ensemble,
c'est déjà pas mal ?
Euh...
J'ai fait de la paperasse depuis ce matin
donc je n'ai pas écrit de chapitre,
je n'ai même pas expliqué à Mélanie ce que je faisais.
Je fais un vlog durant tout le mois...
Je ne vais pas m'y mettre tout de suite
parce que je vais tourner une vidéo
pour vous aujourd'hui.
Avec plein de données à traiter.
Et qui va m'aider à traiter
les données cette semaine ?
On ne sait pas !
[Mélanie] Je ne sais pas.
[Fab] Euh... Aucune id... on...
[Fab] Peut-être Michel et Micheline...
[Mélanie] Oui, so...
[Fab] Je ne vous ai pas présenté
Michel et Micheline !
[Fab] Ici nous vous présentons Michel !
[Fab] Michel qui aspire !
Donc Michel qui est un aspirateur.
[Fab] Et il n'est pas seul...
puisqu'il est accompagné
maintenant de sa femme
à savoir Micheline
Micheline, elle, elle "serpille"
et je vais bientôt lancer une chaîne geek, parce que...
quand je vois le nombre de conneries
qu'on achète, ici, en électronique.
Il nous reste en fait, des...
jeux, que j'ai envoyé pour les 200 000 abonnés
je pense que je vais les emmener en tournée, comme ça si vous le voulez à la fin, je vous l'offrirai.
Ainsi que des Haribos, peut être
[Fab] : On ne sait pas.
[Mélanie]: Ah non, ça je les garde !
11 janvier, on est repartis en tournée
mais ce coup-ci c'est pas Gary, c'est Diablozor...
Voici mon problème pour poser l'ordinateur
[Rires]
Tiens, ben, vide son portefeuille s'il te plaît.
[Diablozor voix rauque]: Oh ouiiii
[Fabien]: Juste pour vérifier.
Quel sera le sujet de ce prochain chapitre ?
Qu'est ce que tu aimerais trouver dans mon livre?
Quels chapitres ? Je ne sais pas astuces,
trucs de mentalisme ou trucs à faire avec sa tête...
Qu'est ce qui te ferait dire:
"Ah oui put*** ça serait bien ça"
Si j'arrive à le rendre à accessible à lui,
tout le monde pourra le comprendre.
[Diablozor]: Et bé écoutes euh...
[d'un ton "idiot du village"] hein ?
[Fabien]: Là nous allons observer le Diablozor
Le diablozor en période nuptiale
fait des sons étranges dans
un micro, comme pour le régler.
[Diablozor] Hi ! .....  Hi !.... Hi !!
Hey ! Hey, hey ! Hey, hi, hi, hiii !
Et ah, ah, ah.
Avec son fabuleux chant
le Diablozor essaie d’attirer une femelle.
[Diablozor continue les tests en chantonant]
[Diab.] Et, et çà ! Et, et çà !
Et, et ça ! Et, et ça ! Et, et ça ! Et, et ça !
Sa femme, la Pascalette,
[Rires hors cadre]
[Rigolant]
lui ré... lui répond.
Lui répond, en faisant varier les lumières autour d'elle.
Mais la Pascalette NE se fait PAS chopper comme ça
et aussi elle grimpe sur un escabeau
pour challenger le Diablozor
Mais le Diablozor ne se laisse pas faire
et part chopper la Pascalette
qui fait semblant de ne rien voir,
de ne pas être très intéressé
Regardez !
Je pense qu'on va assister à l'accouplement.
[Diab. toujours en tests]
voilà, voilà, voilà !
[Diab] D'accord. C'est là.
Ça va vite à la....
Et c'est à ce moment que le Diablozor s'est rendu compte que c'était un mâle.
[Le Diablozor poursuit ses tests en faisant
des bruits de plus en plus étranges]
C'était le Safari,
Oh put***
C'était le Safari animalier au KFT de Saint Galmier
On fait 2 dates.
Il est 16h30, le public rentre à 19h ce qui me laisse encore le temps d'écrire un chapitre du livre.
Deuxième jour à Saint Galmier au KFT
Une carte bleue bloquée, que je n'arrive pas
à débloquer, je sors de la banque.
Je suis tombé malade.
[Musique en fond sonore]
Je vais éteindre cette musique là.
Donc je disais. Je suis tombé malade.
Je crois que mon corps, en fait, m'a préservé sur
tout 2016, quand je faisais une vidéo par jour
et que là je ne fais que tomber malade,
c'est la seconde fois.
Je suis HS.
Je vous disais hier que j'avais une idée
et je vais la mettre en place là
tout de suite sur Facebook
Sur Facebook, je vais vous demander
de me dire 5 mots au hasard.
Et vous, vous n'allez pas savoir pourquoi.
Vous allez le savoir qu'en voyant cette vidéo,
qu'à ce moment là de la vidéo.
Mais sur le prochain chapitre que j'écrirai, demain.
Je me donne comme défi, de devoir placer, vos 5 mots.
Je choisirai le post avec les 5 mots au hasard.
Mais moi dans le livre, je veux que ce soit cohérent
Je ne veux pas que ce soit
un private joke.
Je veux qu'il n'y ait que vous qui
sachiez à ce moment là du livre.
Qu'il y a une grosse connerie de cachée.
Alors comment je vais formuler ça.
Ça doit paraître chelou de faire ça, mais c'est une bonne solution pour écrire le livre avec vous.
En ayant l'impression de ne pas être tout seul.
C'est plutôt marrant.
C'était bien joué. On ne t'a pas vu disparaître
|Diablozor]:  Tu me vois, tu me vois plus.
Tu me vois, tu me vois plus.
[Diablozor]: Comment on fait avec les 3 violonistes?
[Fabien]: Ah!... ben on les met à côté
des 2 éléphants et du chameau.
[Diablozor]: Exactement
13 janvier, je suis de plus en plus malade,
je perds ma voix.
Là je suis en train de ranger mes affaires,
j'ai fait un petit tour sur Twitter,
Facebook, tout ça...
J'ai vu, genre :
2000 messages sur Facebook,
euh...
je crois qu'il y a 500 Tweets,
un truc comme ça...
Et sur le profil Facebook,
il doit y avoir 300 messages de plus.
Avec les 5 mots que je
vous ai demandé hier.
Donc ça va être drôle.
Et sinon, concernant une vidéo
que vous aurez déjà vue au moment
où vous verrez celle-ci,
celle sur l'effet "mouton-chèvre",
je reçois tous les calculs des mathématiciens,
c'est ouf !
C'est génial pour ça.
Merci Youtube, merci Internet
de me permettre de faire
des expériences comme ça.
Pour l'instant on a déjà collecté
30.000 réponses
Vous imaginez le truc ?
Le seul truc qui est bien quand
tu es malade c'est
que tu as une voix de crooner.
Et ça, ça le fait !
Je ne sais pas ce que ça va rendre
comme son à la caméra.
Bon allez, je finis de ranger.
Et direction Villars
Et oui, je sais :
il faut que j'écrive au moins 2 chapitres aujourd'hui.
Je suis au courant.
Je n'oublie pas
le but de ce mois-ci.
[Les Quatre saisons de Vivaldi - Printemps]
On commence avec une musique
qui frôle l'intelligence quand même...
Et là on passe sur du
Back in black
[Diablozor] C'est de sa faute !
Hein ?
Elle est pas belle la vie ?
[Fab] Elle est pas belle la vie ?
On est le 14, on est à Vienne,
vous vous souvenez, hier on était
à Villars, là on vient d'arriver à Vienne,
on joue ce soir et demain.
[Sonnerie de type clochette]
et c'est une sorte de café-théâtre,
cabaret, où les gens mangent
ce n'est pas très très grand.
Ça peut accueillir 70 personnes je crois.
Et c'est d'ailleurs tout l'intérêt
des tournées de rodage.
Je vais vous parler de ça
deux secondes,
parce que j'ai entendu hier
un spectateur me demander
si on faisait des petites salles
comme ça si on se trompe ce n'est pas très grave ?
Alors, ce n'est pas du tout ça.
Quand on fait une tournée de rodage,
l'intérêt de refaire des petites salles,
de retourner dans les cafés-théâtres
c'est parce que c'est le plus dur,
ça ne ment pas.
D'ailleurs, si je fais quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas
je le saurai tout de suite.
Il n'y aura pas de cadeau.
S'il y a juste la moitié de la salle
qui rit, ben ça fait un bon petit malaise-TV
Mais au moin on sait.
Ce qui fonctionne, on le sait;
Ce qui ne fonctionne pas, on le sait.
Donc c'est le meilleur endroit
pour travailler, en fait.
Parce que dans une salle de 800 places,
par exemple,
si tu as la moitié de la salle qui rit,
tu as 400 personnes qui rient.
Et tu ne te rends même pas compte
que la blague n'a pas trop marché, par exemple.
Les cafés-théâtres c'est sans filet,
on ne peut pas se cacher,
on ne peut pas se mentir,
on ne peut pas se cacher derrière une grosse technique,
ce genre de choses...
Et donc tous les jours, j'ai mon Diablo
qui relève le défi d'essayer de nous faire
les lumières, les sons...
[Fab] On est le combien ?
[Gary] On est 3... 4...
[Gary] : On est le 20 !
[Fab] On est le 20. On est le 20.
Ça veut dire que je n'avais pas donné
de nouvelles de la suite de la tournée
depuis ce dimanche.
Et on est arrivés à Brignoles,
au Famace Théâtre.
T'as vu ?
On dirait une maison...
C'est une maison !
Alors, pourquoi je n'ai pas donné
de nouvelles, parce que
je n'ai pas continué à écrire le livre
depuis lundi.
J'ai pris une pause.
Euh... Parce que : Mardi j'avais
une prestation privée,
mercredi j'avais un rendez-vous,
hier soir je jouais au Trianon.
Énorme !!
Ho là là...
C'est avec lui qu'on fait des pulls angora.
Donc on joue ce soir et demain.
Donc ce qui est sûr c'est que
comme je vais vous faire la vidéo de demain matin
là, tout à l'heure,
je ne continuerai pas à écrire le livre...
euh... durant ce week-end.
Mais il va quand même se passer
des trucs cools à Brignoles.
On est la veille que je vous sorte la vidéo
sur le fait d'avoir un deuxième trophée Youtube.
Vous ne le savez pas encore
au moment où je vous parle, mais
j'ai reçu deux trophées youtube
Ce qui va décaler le planning de mes vidéos
d'une vidéo.
Tiens, je te passe le sac.
Alors je vous fais participer à tout,
c'est terrible.
Bon bref.
On va au théâtre.
La semaine prochaine je serai
à Aix-en-Provence
et c'est là où je vais mettre
un coup pour finir le bouquin.
Je viens juste de finir le spéctacle
de Brignoles,
et je vais aller vous rejoindre pour
qu'on puisse discuter, faire des photos et tout...
avec le marqueur...
Oh, ma ceinture ! Merci beaucoup !
Pourquoi Gary me ramène ma ceinture?
Et bé viens au spectacle
et tu sauras.
[Musique]
[Gary] Tu as ton écharpe ?
[Fab] Mais bien sûr, j'ai mon écharpe.
On est arrivés à Aix-en-Provence depuis hier.
Avec Gary-Jo... Garyzor
cherche pas, t'es mort...
On devait arriver hier à midi dix-sept
hier à Aix-en-Provence
et puis à cause d'un petit problème de train,
très léger, on est arrivés à 17h30 à Marseille...
Formidable...
Mais on a pu jouer quand même hier soir,
c'était cool.
C'est blindé tout la semaine,
c'est rempli, vous êtes là,
vous êtes au top !
C'est Philippe Roche.
Philippe Roche qui était passé sur ma chaîne,
regarde, c'est lui là.
Ouais...
Tun, le mec il est au téléphone et tout...
[Philippe] C'est ça.
[Fab] Ah, depuis que tu as récupéré un téléphone...
[Phil] Toujours au top. Toujours au top.
[Fab] Toujours au top !
[Phil] Qu'est-ce que tu veux...
[Phil] iPhone 4, surtout pas S !
[Phil] Non, ce serait trop.
[Fab] Ah, c'est vrai que ça ressemble à un iPhone.
C'est un truc d'archi-chinois en fait...
[Phil] Attendez...
[Fab] Tu vas bien ?
[Phil] Ça va et bisous.
[Fab] Donc on va à France Bleu,
l'émission s'appelle ?
[Phil] Les Tchatcheurs !
[Fab] Et tu fais partie de cette émission depuis ?
[Phil] Euh... depuis le mois de mai... mars dernier.
[Phil] Ouais, quasi 1 an.
On vient souvent.
[Gary] Hé, tu t'es coiffé avec la poignée de la porte
toi, ou quoi, derrière ?
[Fab] Sans déconner ? Moi ?
[Gary] Ouais.
[Fab] Ouais, ben ouais, c'est sûr.
Ça veut dire que cet après-midi je vais
reprendre l'écriture du livre.
Il faut que je le finisse avant
fin janvier.
Et je suis un petit peu à la BOURRE
quand même.
[journaliste] match de l'OM demain au vélodrome
face à Montpellier
[Jounaliste] Paris Bercy. Midi cinq sur France Bleu
Provence, pas d'alerte au verglas dans
le département.
[Snd journaliste] Non, mais par contre ça va être
quand même assez agité sur toute
la Provence encore cet après midi...
Clap, Clap, Clap.
[Fab] Non mais lui, il cherche la standing ovation
toujours.
[Journ.] Vous vous connaissez tous les deux
depuis pas mal d'années, vous vous êtes
rencontrés sur un bateau en Turquie.
[Fab] Oui. En prison.
[Journ.] Avouez Philippe ?
[Phil] Oui, c'est vrai.
[Fab] Prison Turque.
[Phil] Prison au large d'Istanbul.
Je suis de retour dans l'appartement
d'Aix-en-Provence pour enchaîner l'écriture du livre.
Voici un petit bout de sommaire,
juste là, vous avez vu ?
Maintenant c'est musique à fond dans les oreilles,
et je vais enquiller, je pense,
six heures d'écriture.
[Chuchottant]
A tout'
Voilà, ce premier vlog est terminé
et, en même temps, le premier jet
du livre est terminé.
Ça veut dier que maintenant il y a
beaucoup de travail de relecture,
de choses à affiner,
de choses à améliorer.
Je vais mettre cette vidéo en ligne
dites moi dans les commentaires
si ça vous plaît,
ce genre de truc.
Et qu'on fasse ça tous les mois,
c'est à dire qu'une fois par mois,
le premier de chaque mois,
je vous mets un vlog de
tout le mois passé.
Comme d'habitude, si ça vous a plu,
je compte sur vous pour
vous abonner à la chaîne et surtout
mettre un petit pouce en l'air qui fait plaisir.
Et rendez-vous bientôt.
Ciao !
[Musique Générique de Fin]